hmm
that's so funny
oh
yes
two minute warning on the press reaching
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
no of course not
if anything
is
can't have that hang on
look
um
hi everyone we have a very special guest
today
since his inauguration president biden
has put diplomacy
at the center of united states foreign
policy grounding our international
engagement in american values
rebuilding our alliances and re-engaging
with international institutions
to help strengthen them obviously part
of his visit to the state department
is an emphasis on that but to talk about
the president's visit to the state
department today as well as the
executive actions he will sign on
reengaging
the world with diplomacy we're excited
to welcome national security adviser
jake sullivan to the briefing room
and he's kind enough to take a few
questions i will be the bad cop as per
usual
over here sorry about that
hi everybody it's uh great to have the
opportunity to be here as jen just
mentioned
uh president biden is going to be going
over to the state department to give
remarks on foreign policy and national
security today
it's not an action that he's chosen the
state department as the venue for these
first remarks
that he will make on this subject he
wants to send a clear message that our
national security strategy will lead
with diplomacy
and before he actually gives his speech
he'll meet with career professionals
from the state department's foreign
service and civil service
who are the tip of the diplomatic spear
this is going to be the first in a
series of visits he makes to the
national security workforce
at the pentagon at the intelligence
community and across the u.s government
his remarks are not going to be the
totality of his foreign policy they're
going to be focused on his early
decisions and actions
and those early moves the core strategic
thrust of them
is to establish a position of strength
for the united states to be able to deal
with both great power competition
and the transnational threats that the
american people face
so establishing this position of
strength involves five major lines of
effort
one investments at home to shore up our
country's foundations
and the american recovery plan in that
regard is not just a matter of economic
policy it's a matter of national
security strategy as well
two revitalizing america's alliances
the president has spoken with key allies
in both europe and asia just last night
he had the opportunity to speak with
both the president
of the republic of korea and the prime
minister of australia
and the national security team is
working now with those allies to build
out an ambitious agenda
three re-engaging key institutions and
agreements
as part of a new commitment to
multilateralism and service of america's
national interests
we've rejoined the paris climate accord
and president biden will be hosting a
climate leaders summit in april
we've reversed the decision to leave the
world health organization
we've just yesterday extended the new
start treaty
to maintain strategic nuclear stability
with russia for the next five years
four reasserting our values the
president
in the first two weeks has reversed the
muslim ban
the ban on transgender service members
serving in our military
and today he will announce an end
to american support for offensive
operations
in yemen and five getting our global
force posture right
making sure that our global force
posture is consistent
with our national security and
diplomatic priorities
today he will announce that secretary
austin will lead a global force posture
review
and during the pendency of that review
will freeze
any troop redeployments from germany
now of course establishing a position of
strength also means
building a national security team that's
fit for purpose
and here at the national security
council not only
have we reinforced and reinvigorated
every element of our regional and
functional work
we've added a new deputy for cyber and
emerging technology
we've elevated democracy as a key part
of the national security council's work
we've added a coordinator for the
indo-pacific
and we've begun an intensive review
of our strategies and resources towards
the threat posed by domestic violent
extremism
now our view is that once we have
established this position of strength we
will be able to compete more effectively
with our competitors across the board
and especially with china
in every domain economic diplomatic
technological security
you name it we'll be able to counter
russia more effectively
and will be better equipped to address
threats from climate change
to pandemics to nuclear proliferation
we will also be able to more effectively
pursue a foreign policy for the middle
class
this is not just a tagline it's an
organizing principle for the work that
we will do
so what does that mean what is a foreign
policy for the middle class well it
starts with how we set priorities
everything we do in our foreign policy
and national security will be measured
by a basic metric
is it going to make life better safer
and easier for working families
so of course that means a different
approach to trade policy
we're not about trying to make the world
safe for multinational investment
we're about creating jobs and raising
wages here in the united states
so our priority is not to get access for
goldman sachs in china
our priority is to make sure that we are
dealing with china's trade abuses that
are harming american jobs and american
workers
in the united states so whether it's
dumping
or subsidies or intellectual property
theft
or the countries uh across the world who
have engaged in
problematic currency practices our
priorities in the trade space will be
about the american worker
but it's about much more than that it's
about thinking about national security
as national competitiveness
making investments in our own industrial
and innovation base so that the good
paying jobs and industries of the future
are here in the united
states so build back better isn't just
about economics it's
about national security as well and then
it's about the set of issues that
working families in this country are
facing every day
that are challenging their lives and
livelihoods the pandemic
climate change the threat of domestic
violent extremism
and so from our perspective putting this
middle class and working people at the
center of our foreign policy
isn't just good from a strategic
perspective it's just good common sense
and good
decent values as well so
uh these are some of the things you'll
hear from president biden today
and we will also have the opportunity to
put out a set of executive orders
that establish regular order in our
national security decision making
that revitalize our workforce both in
terms of the skills they have
and and uh to reflect the diversity
equity and inclusion priorities of this
administration
uh and to uh build up a more robust
capacity for the united states
to accept refugees from around the world
so let me stop there and
be happy to take a few questions before
turning the podium back over to jen
yeah jacob thanks for being in the room
we appreciate it first i want to ask you
speak about the president's position of
strength as it relates to russia what
does it say about president biden's
position of strength that after his
conversation
with president putin on issues like the
hack on alexi navalny
and others days after it vladimir putin
basically
ignored it and sentenced navalny to two
and a half years in prison
well first of all unlike the previous
administration we will be taking steps
to hold russia accountable for the range
of malign activities that
uh it has undertaken that includes
interfering in america's democracy it
includes
the poisoning of citizens on european
soil
with chemical weapons it includes the
types of hacks and breaches that you
just referred to
and many other things as well we will do
that at a time
and in a manner of our choosing and we
believe that
imposing those costs and consequences
will have an effect on russia's behavior
going forward now is it going to stop
vladimir putin from doing everything we
don't like
of course not but do we believe that we
will be able to take
a firmer more effective line when it
comes to russian aggression and russian
bad behavior
yes we do at the same time i would just
like to reiterate
that that doesn't rule out being able to
work with russia where it's in our
interest to do so we can walk and chew
gum at the same time
and the new start treaty and that
extension keeping a lid on nuclear
uh proliferation is in fact very much in
america's national security interests
with another top-line issue obviously on
your plate right now as it relates to
kim jong-un and north korea you said
that the president spoke now
to the president of korea of course not
to the head of the dprk there
does this white house does president
biden have any intention
to continue the diplomacy as it relates
to kim jong-un will he meet
with kim jong-un we are conducting a
review of our policy towards north korea
as we speak president biden told
president moon last night
that that review is underway and that we
will consult closely with our allies
particularly the rok in japan in doing
that
and i'm not going to get ahead of that
review yeah
question on immigration when the
president signed his executive order
directing doj
not to contract with private federal
prisons
he did not extend that to dhs and ice
which houses many uh undocumented
immigrants
so is that something that he plans to do
and if so why didn't he do it in that
executive order
i would refer you to dhs and as
secretary myorkis for that
yeah uh the president campaigned on
issuing a presidential
memorandum of making lgbtq human rights
a priority
in u.s foreign policy within one week of
his administration
do you expect us to be rolled into the
announcement today and if so how will
that initiative compare to the
initiative on the previous
administration led by former ambassador
bernal
i appreciate you uh raising the question
i didn't want to steal the president's
thunder but since you asked it directly
he will be announcing
a presidential memorandum on protecting
the rights of lgbtq
individuals worldwide today that will be
part of his remarks at the state
department and it reflects his deep
commitment
to these issues both here in the united
states and everywhere around the world
and the united states will speak
out and act on behalf of these rights as
we go
yes thank you so much just picking up on
peter's question
on uh speaking from a position on
strength i want to talk about
sanctions on myanmar there's the fact
that we have republican lawmakers
who support the claim that the election
was stolen
some potentially having ties to
extremist groups who stormed the capital
doesn't make the job of the
administration's foreign policy team
more difficult to punish countries like
myanmar on the grounds of
violations of democracy and rule of law
on the one hand pulling our country
together revitalizing our own
democratic foundation building more
unity as president biden has talked
about that will be an important part of
us
operating effectively in the world but
when it comes to burma specifically
this is an area where there is genuine
bipartisan agreement
president biden in his remarks today
will talk about some of the outreach he
has done
to republicans on the issue and we
believe we can work with the congress
on a package of sanctions to impose
consequences in
in response to this coup we will also be
working with allies and partners around
the world
quickly on burma the top generals there
have already been sanctioned under the
magnitsky act
and the state department has said that
the administration wants to avoid any
action that could
you know negatively impact the burmese
people so what options specifically in
terms of sanctions
um is the administration considering and
does it include declaring like a new
national emergency via an executive
order
to impose sanctions on more generals or
the military or government as a whole
without getting too far ahead of
ourselves we are reviewing the
possibility of a new executive order and
we are also
looking at specific targeted sanctions
both on individuals
and on entities controlled by the
military that enrich the military so we
believe we have
a plenty of space to be able to find
uh the types of sanctions targets
necessary to sharpen the choice for the
burmese military
yeah on monday iran proposed allowing
the european union to negotiate a
simultaneous return
to the iran nuclear deal the idea being
you know the u.s dropped
sanctions in exchange for iran coming
into clients is that
proposal at all being considered
we are actively engaged with the
european union right now particularly
the three members of the p5 plus one
germany uh the uk and france
uh we are talking to them at various
levels of our government
those consultations i think will produce
a unified front when it comes to our
strategy towards iran and towards
dealing with diplomacy around the
nuclear file
and i just don't want to get ahead of
where that's going to end up you can
take one or two more here
yeah hi will the president announce uh
that he's naming a new envoy for yemen
when he's at the state department
this afternoon yes he will um you know
as i said in my remarks today
uh he is going to announce an end to
american support for offensive
operations in yemen
that is a promise that he made in the
campaign that he will be following
through on
but he will go further than that he will
talk about the united states playing a
more active and engaged role
in the diplomacy to bring an end to the
conflict in yemen and that will include
the naming of a special envoy which will
happen today
last question yeah could you first uh
just real quick on yemen paulo could you
explain a little bit more in detail what
an end to american support for offensive
operations entails
and does that extend to actions against
aqap
uh in in that region and has president
biden informed
the leaders of saudi arabia in the uae
already so it does not extend
to actions against aqap which are
actions that we undertake
in service of protecting the homeland
and protecting american interests in the
region and our allies and partners it
extends to the types of offensive
operations that have perpetuated
a civil war in yemen that has led to a
humanitarian crisis
the types of examples of that include
two arms sales
of precision guided munitions that the
president has
halted that we're moving forward at the
end of the last administration
we have spoken with both
senior officials in the uae and senior
officials in saudi arabia we have
consulted with them
we are pursuing a policy of no surprises
when it comes to these types of actions
so they understand that this is
happening and they understand our
reasoning and rationality
you guys have announced that you're
reviewing a number of uh malign actions
carried out by other countries whether
it's russia
or china or other countries um does
president biden feel a responsibility to
impose consequences for actions
undertaken by other countries in the
last several years
where president trump gave those
countries a pass and if so how far back
does that extend i think the way that
president
biden looks at this is it doesn't matter
who the occupant of the oval office is
if this country gets attacked
if our elections get attacked if our
critical infrastructure gets attacked
if our troops are threatened by foreign
actors he's going to respond
to established deterrence and to impose
consequences so he doesn't have a
particular time or date
from when that starts and he certainly
will look at actions undertaken during
the trump administration as a tax not on
president trump but his attacks on the
united states of america
thank you guys
okay just a couple of other things i
just wanted to go through
uh president biden delivered an address
about faith and unity
at the national prayer breakfast this
morning i should say it was via a video
this event was entirely virtual this
year because of kovid
with all speakers delivering taped
remarks
alongside president biden four living
former president sent messages to the
breakfast
president biden is committed to the
prayer breakfast tradition of reflection
and fellowship especially at this
difficult time
in our nation's history and a little
piece of history for all of you
every president has attended the
breakfast since dwight d eisenhower made
his first
appearance in 1954. a little trivia for
your dinner table
okay a couple of other updates
um the president and his administration
all of us are continuing their close
engagement today on the american rescue
plan a top priority for him and all of
us
at this moment including outreach to
lawmakers and stakeholders as well as
our continuing work to make the case
directly to the american people
we're heartened that congress is moving
quickly on this
over the next several days committees
will have a chance to review the
legislation as you know that's kind of
the next step
uh in the process next week oh actually
after the vote-a-rama uh tonight's very
washington term but that is literally
what it's called
and republicans will have additional
opportunities to provide input
and help improve the final product
that's how the process is supposed to
work
and we're encouraged that there is
agreement on the need to move swiftly
and the goal of making this bipartisan
bill and package there's a couple of
questions that many of you have asked us
and others have asked us
uh over the course of our effort on the
american rescue plan so i just wanted to
address some of those here uh first why
do we need a package of this size or
we'll be fine with the status quo
obviously this is a good question that's
asked as economic
data comes out so i just wanted to
highlight a couple of pieces for all of
you
a cbo report found that without any
additional stimulus our economy wouldn't
reach pre-pandemic levels until
2025 and it would take just as long to
get back to full employment
this week was the 46th consecutive week
that jobless claims have exceeded the
pre-pandemic record high
kevin hassett president trump's top
economic advisor said quote we need to
be risk averse
and that without a major stimulus we
could have a quote negative spiral for
the economy
this is a grim picture but analysis
analysis after analysis
shows us that the rescue plan would make
a huge difference
moody's analytics found it would get us
to full employment a year
faster brookings predicts it would get
us back to pre-pandemic levels by the
end of the year
and over 90 percent of economists
surveyed by reuters found it would drive
substantial
growth the second question we often get
another good question
is when we will see bipartisan support
for this bill
the reality is we see it every single
day a sir new survey from navigator
research out this morning shows 72
percent
of americans support the rescue plan
including 53 percent of republicans
a quinnipiac poll yesterday found that
68 percent of americans back the rescue
plan
a yahoo yougov survey on monday showed
that over two-thirds
support the package so i just wanted to
highlight a couple of those pieces those
are excellent questions we get in here
but we did a little thinking about your
questions last thing i just wanted to do
at the top um kristin who's back today
again
asked a great question about the artemis
program which i dug into and i'm very
excited about it now to tell my daughter
all about it
so for those of you who have not been
following it as closely
through the artemis program the united
states government will work with
industry and international partners to
send astronauts to the surface of the
moon
another man and a woman to the moon
which is very exciting
uh conduct new and exciting science
prepare for future missions to mars
and demonstrate america's values to date
only 12
humans have walked on the moon that was
half a century ago
the artemis program a waypoint to mars
provides exactly
uh you know the opportunity to add
numbers to that of course
um lunar exploration has broad and
bicameral support in congress most
recently detailed in the fy
2021 omnibus spending bill and certainly
we support this effort and endeavor
why don't we go to you first darlene
thank you uh can you update us on the
president's thinking on the issue of
forgiving student loan debt
there are some groups that are pushing
anew for the president to
forgive all student loan debt and where
where does he stand on that
sure the president has
and continues to support canceling
ten thousand dollars a federal student
loan debt per person as a response to
the coveted crisis
he's calling on congress to draft the
proposal and if it is
if it is passed um and sent to his desk
he will look forward to signing it
uh debt relief is of course an important
priority for the president
on day one the first day of his
administration he directed the
department of education to extend the
existing pause on student loan payments
and interest for millions of americans
with federal student loans
that was the step he took through
executive action but he certainly
supports
efforts uh by members in congress to
take additional steps and he would look
forward to signing it
so he would do that through legislation
and not an eo not an executive order
well i think he uh took the step uh
already took a step through an executive
action on the first day and he would
look to congress to take the next steps
second question there's been some uh
discrepancies in the numbers of these
fema
supported vaccination centers that the
president wanted
created a heat call for 100 do you have
an update on
how many have actually been set up as of
today
and any of them set up before the
president
took office uh well this is a priority
to the president uh and setting up those
vaccination sites
through the uh and by through
partnership with fema is something that
he feels on our health and econo our
health and
medical experts feel as a way to get
more vaccines in the arms of americans
in terms of the specific numbers that
have been set up to date there's new
updates every single day i know that
i'm sure the team can provide an update
on how many have been set up
uh when they do their briefing tomorrow
uh i will say that there were some
really interesting
updates that i received this morning
about efforts to
set up large-scale sites in texas
obviously there's some that are being
set up in california
they're looking for space where they can
have
great capacity to bring people in uh and
vaccinate as many people as possible but
it's ongoing and i'm sure the health and
health team will be able to provide an
update on the specific numbers go ahead
thank you um i just wanted to ask if uh
president biden will sign the refugee
executive order today and then a follow
up on that
uh he the president is certainly
committed to looking for ways to
ensure more refugees are welcomed into
the united states it's a priority to him
personally but
i don't expect him to make uh sign a
specific executive order today
do you expect him to announce his intent
to raise the cap for the
fiscal year for refugees to like a
pro-rated annual 125
000 which would be around uh i guess 80
000 for the year
i think new york times reported that i
expect him to talk about his commitment
to refugees um but i'm not going to get
ahead of any other specific
announcements he'll make in the speech
uh you guess a lot of there's been good
reporting as
jake confirmed a lot of pieces go ahead
mario thanks jen
has the president been briefed yet from
secretary ellen's meeting this morning
with financial regulators over
market volatility like gamestop and
is he expecting her to deliver potential
options to
address that i would send you to the
department of treasury obviously they
oversaw
the meeting i'm not even sure what time
it took place i would defer to them on
that
and any specific details they want to
read out from it go ahead jeremy
one of the biggest criticisms of
president trump's approach to handling
the coronavirus was that the
administration didn't provide clear
guidance to states
about when they should shut down when
they should reopen um dr vivek murthy
back in november talked about a national
alert system
uh that that would be needed um is that
something that the administration is
planning to implement
uh some kind of color-coded system to
tell states you know when
you know by which criteria they should
reopen or shut down is that something
you guys are considering or planning to
implement
i'm happy to talk to our health team and
you'll have another briefing with them
tomorrow
obviously a number of options are under
consideration to
uh both make sure americans are safer
and that we're doing everything
necessary to communicate with them
accurately how to keep themselves and
their families safe
but also how to better communicate with
governors and mayors some of that
is reopening the line of communication
which
was somewhat shut at times according to
governors
during the last administration and
ensuring which is one of the things that
governors have requested
they have a better heads up on how many
vac how many vaccines
they will have access to so they can do
better planning also working with them
and tapping into fema a question that
came up earlier
uh utilizing their resources to be able
to
uh kind of mass vaccinate um people in
uh larger locations so those are a lot
of the ways that we're implementing it
to date there are a range of options on
the table but
i don't have any updates on an alert
system alert system i don't
i don't have any update on it um but
again you'll have an opportunity to talk
to our health team tomorrow and that's a
good question to ask them
secondly american airlines and united
airlines are planning to furlough about
27
000 employees by the end of next month
as their federal payroll
aid runs out does president biden
support giving
those airlines more financial aid
and does he support including that in
this corona virus relief package
i think the president's uh priorities
are already in the package
and they are focused on ensuring there's
funding to get vaccines in the arms of
americans funding to reopen schools
ensuring that the one in seven americans
who families who can't put food on the
table is worried about that is able to
do that
as you know there's a process that will
be ongoing on capitol hill
over the course of the next days and
through the course of next week where
there will be amendments put forward
to work on committees but i think the
priorities of the president already
in the bill and just a foreign policy
question um a real haines
made clear that she would absolutely uh
comply with the law requiring the
intelligence community to
provide congress with a declassified
report on who was responsible
for the death of the journalist jamal
khashoggi when can we expect to see that
and is president biden considering
sanctioning saudi arabia
for that murder of jamal khashoggi
well as you noted that review would come
out of the intelligence community and it
will
be released on the timeline of when it's
completed and we certainly would never
take a step to
expedite or change the timeline that
works best for them
uh and then as jake also noted there's
an ongoing review of a range of our
foreign policy our national security
policies uh certainly
including in terms of our relationship
with saudi arabia
um but i don't have anything to preview
for you at this point in time go ahead
peter
as it relates to coven relief you said
the president wants to take care of
people that need the help
the most obviously a lot of americans
right now say that they need
help so how do you determine who needs
help and who doesn't where do you draw
that line
well again peter i think what we're
hoping to do through the package
is uh provide assistance to
americans who are struggling to make
ends meet at this moment in time and
you're right there are
there's a large swath of americans who
are struggling through this moment in
time because they fear
about their health the health of their
grandparents of their cousins of their
parents
and also people who worry about their
kids going back to school and
you know their desire to get their kids
back in school and continue learning
uh the package itself again is of course
a priority of the president
it is not the end of our uh work or the
end of his efforts to
help bring relief to the american public
um it is a first step
as you noted as you as he noted i should
say he's also going to talk about his
build back better agenda
in the coming months and that's
something that will certainly build on
this as well
i guess how soon for the americans who
are listening to every word that's here
how soon should they expect
that relief to come and can you
guarantee that it's going to be there
before the march 14 deadline
when unemployment insurance for example
expires you're right and that's
something that we're very mindful of
here the president's mindful of the vice
president's mindful of our economic team
is
certainly mindful of uh peter and that's
one of the reasons why
the president has been so firm in his
insistence that
the 1400 checks remain intact and that
they go out to the american people
there's a process underway in congress
next week the committees will be doing
the work that they should be doing that
they do through the record the budget
reconciliation process
we have been very clear about our own
view of the urgency here and we're
hopeful that
uh and we're confident that uh congress
shares our view of that the president
talked about bipartisanship he's met
with senate republicans
then senate democrats then spoke to
house democrats
when is he going to meet with or speak
to house republicans
he's every single day he seems to be he
is meeting with
members of both parties engaging with
members of both parties uh that work is
not done but i don't have a meeting to
announce for you here today
has he spoken or has he met with kevin
mcarthur yet the leader of the i don't
have any calls to read out for you our
team remains in touch again with
democrats and republicans members of our
economic team
members of our political teams we are
certainly engaged with all offices that
have an interest in engaging with us
last question if i can't hunter biden
has a memoir to be published in april
i guess my question is is that book
subject to the clearance process do a
clearance review
uh well there for those of you who had
not seen the news it was announced i
believe by simon
schuster this morning i do have a
statement from
joe and jill biden in their personal
capacity as his parents
we admire our son hunter strength and
courage to talk openly about his
addiction
so that others might see themselves in
his journey and find hope
this is a personal book about his own
personal journey
and i will leave it at that go ahead can
you give us a sense of the
scope and scale of u.s commitment to
covet
beyond the four billion dollars i have
been approved by congress for
gabby the vaccine alliance in december i
believe will there be additional funding
for provides
uh we have reiterated our commitment to
kovacs i don't have any additional
funding though to announce today
can you also just comment on the
administration position on the vaccine
diplomacy that's being employed by china
as well as india
and well tell me a little bit more about
what you're looking for
so so what's the administration's
position on countries like china and
india who's essentially using vaccine to
buy
influence to improve diplomatic ties
with other countries what's the
administration's position on that
uh well our position is that we're
focused on ensuring that the american
people are vaccinated that we are
getting as many shots in the arms of
americans as possible we rejoined the
world health organization so that
the united states can have a seat at the
global table
in order to play a constructive role in
getting safe and effective vaccines in
the arms of americans i'll leave it at
that go ahead
can you have do you have a comment on
the burmese diplomat
who is seeking asylum because then i
hope i cannot accept the illegitimate
legitimate takeover of power by the
military i'll have to talk to our uh
national security team about that go
ahead
republic some republicans and some
centrist democrats have said that a
minimum wage increase
does not belong in a coveted relief bill
so is president biden
willing to drop the 15 minimum wage in
order to get bipartisan support for that
package
uh well the president feels strongly
that we need to raise the minimum wage
and many economists agree with him
and looks forward to working with
congress to do it whether it can be done
through the reconciliation process will
be determined according to the house and
senate but i'm not going to negotiate
further from here
does he believe though that the 15
minimum wage
needs to be in this package in this deal
i heard your question um i think what
i'm saying is he's committed to raising
the minimum wage he thinks it's an
important step
for american workers and for american
families there's obviously a process
that's ongoing the reconciliation
process
uh that will make some determinations
about what can and cannot be in the bill
based on rules
go ahead a question about dhs before my
question is about
whether or not president biden believes
or
plans to in any way make sure that
detention centers for undocumented
immigrants that those are no longer
contracted with with private companies
it's not a question about dhs it's a
question about what president biden's
beliefs are and what he plans to do
well i think what the president did was
sign an executive order to put
the power in the hands of the department
of homeland security and secretary
mayorkas to
conduct a review and determine what the
path forward is he has spoken about
uh his concern about uh these facilities
in the past that remains the case but it
is under the purview of the department
of homeland security to make
recommendations to the president of the
united states so that was what jake was
conveying
well he had used the previous executive
order though to direct the department of
justice
not to renew contracts anymore with
private prisons
so what i'm asking is why he did not
also direct the department of homeland
security to do the same
there's a new secretary of the
department of homeland security i will
hopefully he'll come to this briefing
room and talk more about these very
important issues but
we're not going to get ahead of his
decision-making process the president
himself has personally
spoken about this issue as as you've
noted and others have noted
uh but we'll have more uh we'll defer to
the secretary of homeland security for
more specifics about the path forward
go ahead kristen and thank you for
getting back to me about artemis folks
at nasa appreciate it
absolutely um yesterday the head of the
cdc
as you know said that it was safe to
reopen schools without vaccinating
teachers
you said that the white house was still
waiting to waiting for the official
guidance before making
a final determination why isn't what
the director of the cdc says why isn't
that enough
well first the the director of the cdc
also has said they haven't issued their
final
guidance and we of course wait for that
process
to complete and see its way through as
she would say as well i believe she did
an interview
last night where she spoke to this issue
again the president
let me be crystal clear wants schools to
open he wants them to stay
open and that is and he wants to do that
safely
and he wants health and medical experts
to be the guides
for uh how we should do exactly that so
we're just not
she the the dr wolinski um
spoke to this uh in her personal
capacity obviously she's the head of the
cdc but we're going to wait for the
final guidance to come out
so we can use that as a guide for
schools around the country and so if
this
final guidance come out comes out and it
says that it is
fine for schools to reopen without
vaccinating teachers can you say now
that that is what
president biden will support well i'm
happy i hope you'll come back whenever
it whenever the guidance comes out
the president has prioritized believes
it should be a priority for
teachers to be vaccinated uh he also
though believes that
even with vaccinations for teachers or
for any american
that there are a number of other
mitigation steps that are important to
take
mass and i'm sure this will be in the
guidance when it comes out um
uh or they'll speak to it i should say
uh matt the wearing of masks
social distancing ventilation these are
all factors that are important for
americans and also for the reopening of
schools
that's one of the reasons that we need
funding in order to be able to
effectively ensure that public schools
across the country
uh are able to do that one more question
on this point
uh michael bloomberg said yesterday that
it's time
for president biden to stand up and say
that the kids are the most important
thing
and stand up to the teachers unions
if it comes down to a binary choice and
there's no indication that you know the
teachers union in chicago or san
francisco are willing to budge at this
point
if it comes down to a binary choice who
would the president
choose the kids or the teachers i i
think that's a little bit unfair how you
pose that question but i will say
the president believes school should be
open teachers want schools to be open
families want schools to be open but we
want to do it safely
and i'm not sure that any parent in this
country would disagree with wanting
their kids
to go to school in a safe environment
where there's ventilation
where proper precautions are taken
whether it's masks or social distancing
and that's his priority but there should
be no confusion the president of the
united states wants schools to open he
wants them to
stay open and that is key too he doesn't
want them to be open for a month
that's disruptive for teachers for
students for
families uh so he wants the proper steps
to be taken so that they can
be reopen and stay stay open go ahead
one quick one on china
a state department spokesman said on
wednesday that the united states was
deeply disturbed by reports of
systematic rape and sexual abuse
against women in internment camps for
ethnic uighurs
and other muslims in china xinjiang
region and that there must be serious
consequences for atrocities committed
there
and i wondered if you could say anything
about what serious consequences are
currently under consideration
i i don't think i can get ahead of the
president or frankly the secretary of
state we certainly of course
agree with that uh those comments and
statements um from the state department
but i don't have anything to preview for
you in terms of specific actions
go ahead how's the president use the
defense production act to boost
production of vaccines or vaccine
equipment
and if not yet why not so we talked
about this
a little bit yesterday but i know it's a
popular and
good question so dpa ratings which
you're probably familiar with but
everybody may not be which kind of gives
an assessment
of what stock and supply is available is
something that we use
as a guide um and they're in place to
give us a sense of relevant item and
items available
the president invoked the defense
production act because he wanted to have
the capacity or wanted his team to have
the capacity to
address shortfalls when needed and we
are constantly
monitoring that so all options are on
the table in terms of how we would use
the defense production act
and what we would use it to
help produce in terms of relevant
equipment or resources
i expect we'll have uh more of an update
maybe even as soon as tomorrow on how
specifically we're planning to use it so
obviously you're tracking where the
shortfalls are you have not seen the
need to
formally push forward with it yet at
this point well i think i would say that
um
one there are ongoing conversations with
companies and manufacturers about
capacity and what steps could be taken
and as i mentioned the ratings because
we
assess when there are needs right when
we assess when there are needs to
produce
syringes or masks or things along those
lines and then we can act very quickly
but again there's a
update from our there's a briefing from
our coveted team tomorrow um
and hopefully they'll have more to say
on exactly this topic go ahead in the
back
thanks i just wanted to clarify some
questions on energy sector
sure light of the cancellation the
keystone pipeline uh just wondering what
the feet are of other proposed projects
including if the president supports
governor whitmer's calls to scrap
a pipeline that cuts through michigan
powers up the great lakes and into
ontario does he support
her calls to cancel that i i have not
talked to our
climate team about specifically uh that
pipeline of course i think we've noted
that
a number under review um but i will see
if there's an update on that particular
pipeline from also
approved permits that would carry oil
from canadian territories into alaska is
that under review or
uh you know i think again uh all of
these pipelines are a part of
what our climate team is looking at and
assessing uh i haven't seen another
update from them
on an additional step but i will see if
there are any updates to report back
finally
uh on his call with the president
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
requested canada be exempt from buy
america provisions
has the president made a decision on
whether canada would be accepted
i don't think we have any update on that
particular question go ahead
today's print cooler i'm going to ask a
question for sure myself
and behalf of my colleague who can't be
here because public restrictions
uh clearly on lgbtq issues the president
is ready to make good on his promises
uh over the course of the campaign with
the two executive orders he signed in
the first days of office relating to
non-discrimination and the transgender
military ban and just moments ago we had
jack sullivan say he's
the president's gonna sign a memorandum
for lgbtq human rights
uh worldwide however the cornerstone of
the president's
promise to the lgbt community was the
equality act which would be legislation
to expand the
prohibition on anti-lgbtq discrimination
uh the president said he would sign that
legislation within 100 days in office
does he stand by that
he stands by it i i would say that
there's some actions that need to be
taken
by congress of course as you know um and
we're only on day
what are we on now 15 okay so 16
17. all right yeah right around there uh
so we have 85
days to go the president himself speak
out on this legislation
you know i think the president has been
out speaking out about a range of issues
he's committed to
including many on lgbtq rights um over
the course of the last two weeks of his
presidency and
he will continue to be but i don't have
any uh scheduling
updates for you at this point in time
sure
texas is expected to collect planned
parenthood out of its medicaid program
imminently after a federal appeals court
ruled it could do so is the fine
administration plan to step in and take
action as was done under the obama
administration
to prevent states from cutting planned
parenthood and other abortion providers
for medicaid programs
well the president's views are clear and
consistent on this issue just last week
in an executive order
he reissued guidance specifying that
states cannot refuse medicaid funding
for planned parenthood and other
providers hhs would certainly have more
specific
details but they have stated they're
committed to protecting and
strengthening the medicaid program as is
the president
uh consistent with the executive order
we released last week
go ahead kitty thanks jen um i know you
said that you will not talk about
marjorie taylor green in the briefing
room but i want to try this question
another way
sure um what is the president's stance
on a majority party
potentially establishing a precedent
that would result in the stripping of
committee assignments as republicans
look i would say that um it's not the
role of the president
or the role of the white house press
secretary to do
analysis on the uh you know
fissures in the republican party um and
the actions that may be taken in
congress as a result
another one what is the president's view
on the bill that senator romney is
expected to introduce today
it could include up to forty two hundred
dollars per child to families that would
eliminate existing welfare programs and
tax credits
is that compromise or would that be a
non-starter uh i i know that reporting
just came out i believe right before i
came out here so i haven't spoken to the
economic team about it
um certainly efforts to provide
additional funding for i believe you
said child tax credit
child tax credit it would actually uh
eliminate existing welfare programs
and uh some existing tax credits well
let
again the reporting just came out right
as i was walking out here so i haven't
talked to our economic team about it um
we certainly
welcome um efforts or offers um
from uh the uh our republican friends
uh for discussion and and how we can
improve the american recovery plan but
we
i haven't done any they haven't done any
analysis i think quite yet on on senator
romney's uh
proposal go ahead peter jen um we saw
some new figures today more than 2
million
guns were sold in january that was an 80
jump in the second highest monthly total
on record a lot of this of course had to
do with
all the coverage related to the capital
rights then the president promised to
act on day one on this issue of course
we know there's only so much he can do
by executive
action on it where does this fall on his
list of legislative
priorities there's only so much capital
that you have in these first 100 in
first few days
you're right and he has an ambitious
plan on a lot of areas and on a lot of
issues i will say
um as vice president and even before
that uh the president
took on the nra twice and won this is an
issue he has personally committed to
um we are many in this building are
personally committed to
and uh you know i think he would love to
see action
on uh additional gun safety measures to
protect families and children
and uh knows that there is support
across the american public for that
of course i guess that's up to him
though for there to be action so when
would he take action and put some
proposal before congress
well i think we have a couple of
proposals currently before congress but
again this is an issue he has personally
committed to
uh he has a personal um you know uh has
worked on it uh
many times in the past but i don't have
a date for you on
uh when there would be a proposal i want
to ask you if there's a there's an nbc
news video that went viral of a grocery
store in naples florida you may or may
not have seen this if you haven't i'll
describe it to you when you panic
give us a play-by-play when you pan the
grocery store you see that almost
everybody in there is not wearing
a mask even though it's in a county i
believe where masks are mandated the
question is beyond urging
americans to wear masks what
specifically is this white house doing
to combat that resistance especially
given the concerns
about the coronavirus mutations and
others right now well
um one we are trying to communicate
about it as as frequently as possible
obviously as you see i wear a mask out
here i take it off when i come to the
podium
based on the recommendations and advice
of our health and medical experts
you all are wearing masks right now uh
and the president has taken steps uh
that is
uh that are possible through his federal
authorities including mandating them on
public
lands uh on airplanes uh but part of
what we're also trying to do is make our
health and medical experts available to
ensure people understand and i'll
reiterate it here today
it's not just a vaccine is obviously an
incredible medical breakthrough
and we want every american to have one
but even after that vaccinated
uh social distancing wearing masks are
to me going to be essential and
we'll need to continue communicating
about that through health and medical
experts so what do you say to those
folks what do you say to the folks like
those that we saw
in this video i believe one of the folks
who owns or runs that store who said
he doesn't believe that 450 000
americans have died at corona virus at
the end of the day
we need everybody on board to beat this
virus what do you tell them
uh we try to uh fight the misinformation
with facts peter and fight it with
health and medical experts including at
a national level at a local level
to convey to people that wearing a mask
is something that not only can save the
lives of their neighbors but of their
family members
it's quite uh and it's it's steps
they're taking to protect themselves i
mean
we know statistically or from our health
experts i should say
that if americans were amassed for 100
days 50 000 lives would be saved um
we know it's not going to be overnight
but we're going to continue to
communicate about it in a non-political
way in a factual way
so that americans can take steps to save
themselves where does the white house
proposal of sending a mask to every
american stand and how much would that
cost if you followed through
well there are a range of options on the
table to help protect more americans
from the coronavirus and encourage
people to mask up and as i said
that's vital to us because it's not just
about the vaccine it's also about social
distancing
ventilation and certainly wearing masks
but no decision has been made to do that
so i don't have a cost assessment
obviously it would depend on how many
people would be sent a mask
thank you everyone
oh